[Music]
and that story on many of the front
pages as we begin the press preview this
evening a first look at sunday's papers
tonight we'll check out the headlines
with journalist and author rachel shabby
and columnist for the article ally
mirage evening to both of you speak in a
moment first of all let's check out
those front pages for you starting with
the telegraph as fuel shortages continue
the paper reports that the prime
minister is encouraging hgv firms to
increase drivers pay in order to get
more lorries on the road
the sunday express believes such a move
would put christmas back on track
the mail claims ministers are accusing
an hgv boss of triggering the fuel panic
the sunday times here's boris johnson
intends to ask for a change of focus to
nuclear power to solve the problem
turmoil at the labour party conference
is the main story for the observer with
leader sakir stama forced into a climb
down over how its internal elections
will be run
while the mirror has a pledge from the
labour leader to tax private schools to
fund the education of poorer children
here's your scotland on sunday carrying
an investigation into private members
clubs owned by russian and american
billionaires including donald trump it's
alleged that in some cases they claimed
more than a million pounds through a
government-run coveted job retention
scheme
and the sunday people has a plea from
football and marcus rashford for the
government to scrap plans to axe the
20-pound universal credit uplift
and the sunday star speaks to our former
sky news colleague eamon holmes
and as i'm uh as i was saying earlier
tonight i'm joined by rachel shabby and
ali mirage great to see you this
saturday evening thanks for being with
us let's start off then shall we with
the front of the day
sunday telegraph these details just
coming in rachel the government going to
change visa rules for 500 5 000
truckers in europe and five and a half
thousand
poultry workers now we're told that
we're short of a hundred thousand
truckers so i mean these numbers really
are poultry aren't they
oh i see what you just did there um they
kind of are but you know it's a start i
suppose and look the measures to
increase pay
and you know
accelerate training are obviously both
good things um hgv drivers it's a tough
job it's long hours 50 to 60 hour weeks
not very sociable hours either not
amazingly well paid at all
um and so it's only right that those
drivers be paid more and hopefully uh be
offered better conditions as well but
that uplift in visas is really i mean
you're right it's really not going to
cut it more to the point you have to
wonder whether you know after
telling
eu workers to basically go home to say
you're not welcome here in all those
years of brexit
to then say to them oh yeah you can come
back but only for a few months you have
to go away again in christmas it's not
the most enticing prospect is it um it's
quite likely that those drivers might
choose to work in other parts of europe
instead so there's that yeah but it's a
bit unfair to blame brexit on all of
this i mean they're facing shortages
right across europe aren't they it's not
just a uk problem
i mean i think that's i don't know where
that information has come from
um the the the shortest we're not we
don't have fuel in this country at the
moment the shortage is entirely because
of the shortage of truck drivers we have
people in the industry saying it's
because of covid and brexit so why would
we deny the presence of either okay
let's uh put those questions to ali then
and show you the front of the sunday
express as always taking a positive look
on things christmas back on track um is
it fair to blame brexit ali for this and
do you think that these drivers actually
won't want to come over
no i don't think it's totally fair to
blame brexit brexit is one factor in
fact the rhode haulage association did a
useful little graph of various factors
including pay a demographic issues i
mean there's an aging population amongst
the lorry driver community and this has
been a ticking time bomb for uh quite a
while now so this is not just a an issue
that's arisen now it should have been
dealt with a long time before uh brexit
is part of it yes there has been an
exodus of drivers and coven has also
played its part thirty thousand lorry
driver tests did not take place there's
been an exodus of about a hundred
thousand driver shortage that we have at
the moment and the other thing to
remember is that jonathan if you go back
over the past 10 years the average pay
for a lorry driver has risen 19
whereas that of a supermarket worker has
risen 40
so i do think there are structural
issues here to be dealt with so look i
think
as rachel says you know like 5000 is a
start i think the the government is very
acutely aware of the fact that it can't
be seen to cancel christmas yet again
that would be an absolute disaster for
the government and the government which
is actually doing fairly well in the
polls at the moment is actually very
mindful of the fact that
the first duty of any government is to
protect the security of its citizens and
their second duty is to keep the lights
on uh there's a cost of living crisis
looming richie sunnac has got to come
out with his budget on the 27th so
there's a lot of things to deal with
here we've also got you know the cut to
universal credit and various other
issues which uh several tory back joints
are also very very uncomfortable okay so
the government has got a really
difficult position to deal with right
now ali just very quickly um do you
drive have you got a car have you have
you've tried to fill up today
uh no i haven't actually i do have a car
but i i only drive it about once about
to go to the countryside but i actually
went on the train which actually was a
sensible thing to do given the the cues
that were in amisham where i was
yesterday yeah i i think i did the right
thing yeah i think you probably did i
mean the queues are horrific aren't they
rachel i know we've already discussed
the fact that you're not driving at the
moment let's look at the front page of
the uh sunday observer european drivers
will not want to come to the uk that's
what we were discussing uh a bit earlier
uh but the problem is really us isn't it
it's drivers who are uh queueing up at
petrol stations when actually they don't
need to because there is enough
petrol to go round it's just it's not
it's just that we're we're being selfish
oh rachel that rachel's frozen so again
i'm going to come back to you ally i
mean you know we we have a
responsibility to do the right thing
here as well don't we as motorists
yeah we do and look as soon as the
government says uh you know
don't panic don't fill up that's the
first thing that people do which is an
understandable reaction but
unfortunately it's a bit like when
people say don't don't
don't have a run on your bank and
everyone tries to extract their savings
it's exactly the same problem but look
the government has got some contingency
plans in place it has got the army on
standby if necessary to drive these
tankers uh to transport petrol around
the place so i do think there are
contingencies in place but
look the the visas that they're giving
out there is a shortage in europe so
it's going to be interesting to see
whether we can get additional lorry
drivers here and attract them uh given
the current situation there's i mean
look it looks like the british retail
consortium is saying it was very
difficult to secure them yeah we've got
rachel back now so let's look at the
front of the sunday times rachel is uh
is the new nuclear age a solution
yeah i mean firstly just a very quick
rebuttal on the thing about brexit
because it does feel a bit like
this conversation is happening in a
parallel universe if if it wasn't in
part about brexit then we wouldn't need
to put
you know an extra 5 000 visas for hgv
drivers
on the list
of skills that were needed from the eu
there would be no need for that if it
wasn't brexit that was caught the
shortage so please let's not no no
and ali ali made the point that you know
that brexit is part of the problem
there's no doubt about it brexit is part
of the problem but but there are lots of
other reasons as well i think we can we
can all agree on on that
we've got a couple of minutes left so
just tell me about this story in the
sunday times it's an interesting take
isn't it about the the new nuclear age
i don't really know where this has come
from the idea that we would um you know
address this uh energy
shortage by switching to nuclear energy
i mean it's such a throwback
um energy nuclear is just like an energy
of the past it's unwieldy it's more
expensive it's a pollutant
nobody knows what to do with the waste
all the money that could be going into
green renewable energy would be plowed
into that instead i can only assume this
has come from rishi sunak i can only
assume that that's you know he's in some
way been pressured by the nuclear lobby
because it really doesn't make any sense
in any other context ali
yeah i disagree with rachel actually i
think it makes sense in the sense that
you've got to have base load power when
you have a situation where the wind is
not blowing especially at the moment
which is partly causing these issues
where we don't have that much sun in
this country and where we don't have
battery storage up to the levels we need
to at the moment i mean it's evolving
it's evolving technology you need to get
your base load power from somewhere yes
we've got electricity interconnectors
with a continent but even those have had
problems so nuclear has got to be part
of the solution i agree that there are
issues with nuclear but it's got to be
part of the solution and it should have
been a long time ago we know all the
issues that happen with hinkie point c
the fact that there was chinese
involvement in that it looks like these
new nuclear reactors are going to be
involving rolls royce and others
westinghouse etc because there is a
security issue to be also taken into
account when it comes to making these
decisions yeah okay um i'm rachel from
the sunday telegraph matt
as always uh hitting the nail on the
head tell us about the cartoon
well this is matt saying um that panic
buying
has been banned a fuel and only the
nonchalant can fill up with petrol which
you know is very troll i saw a car i saw
a cartoon going around with um pretty
patel's gum boats in in the channel
aimed at a dinghy full of migrants with
you know someone on the gumbo asking can
any of you drive a lorry
which uh
i found a lot more appropriate to the
situation
yeah um interesting intriguing uh all
right thank you both very much for the
moment uh stay where you are because
coming up we'll discuss infighting in
the labour ranks as their party
conference gets underway in brighton
that's after the break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview uh ali and rachel still with us
uh rachel let's look at the front of the
observer i mean this is quite a headline
isn't it for uh for a left-leaning paper
stammer faces wave of anger over labour
conference chaos
uh well i'd say that was pretty accurate
reporting of the situation with labour
at the conference in brighton this year
um kierstama labour leader decided a few
days ago to
try and change rules by which the party
leader is elected making them less
democratic and sidelining the membership
which did not go down well um not with
the membership and not with the unions
either who
um pretty much slated the idea
um in initial talks
and have now agreed a sort of diluted
version which now has to go to the
conference floor but the anger is
about the proposal itself and also about
the way that it's been managed uh the
deputy leader uh angela rainer has
reported in this piece as being um
pretty nonplussed by the whole thing by
the fact that it allowed that star
marine mismanaging this allowed
attention to focus on you know these
very inward-looking rule changes as
opposed to outward-looking policy
specifically uh the policies that rayna
herself
was showcasing today to do with um
workers rights and strengthening those
yeah i mean that's the problem ally
isn't it that uh as the conference gets
underway labour aren't fighting the
tories but they're fighting each other
it's a bigger belief jonathan i'm off to
brighton tomorrow for a little bit of
entertainment really i mean i was hoping
that the labour party would finally step
up and give us some serious opposition
which actually we demand the country
needs it but instead
yet again the party's in dereliction of
duty inward looking at naval gazing i
mean why starmer is picking this fight
now is beyond me presumably he thinks
he'll be leader for a while or maybe not
maybe this is a priority for him what he
should be talking about is aspiration
about cost of living crisis i mean when
he did his earlier reset in february
this year his big idea was covered
recovery bonds another gimmick which
fell flat so you know some people one
labour mp said to me today this is uh
starmar's clause 4 moment going back to
tony blair in 2005 when he made this
commitment not to nationalize industry
anymore it's not a clause 4 moment it's
an inward-looking irrelevance the labour
party needs to get serious at the moment
if they're not going to move beyond
critical race theory palestinian debates
and debates about uh women-only refugees
where their own mps can't even go to
their conference i'm afraid it's looking
bleak for the labour party and not good
for the country either rachel do you
want to come back on that very quickly
before we move on
i do think there's something to be said
for it's not just uh the left of the
party that is getting frustrated with
stammer um it's across the party now um
he should be landing punches on a
government that has
you know many many failings we're in the
middle of uh several crises fuel crisis
energy costs um looming cuts to
universal credit and people just reeling
and struggling um coming out of uh the
pandemic as well
so it should be quite easy to land
punches on this government stoma hasn't
managed to do that but also
just an a vacuousness of ideas there
just aren't any there's been several
reboots but nothing in those reboots um
and it does seem that all the leadership
wants to do
is to attack like left flank of the
party okay um we've only got one minute
left so ali just tell us very quickly
about this story on the front of the
sunday telegraph the navy offering
canada help uh when it comes to russia
and china
yeah they want to uh effectively operate
uh in canada in the arctic which is
becoming an area of strategic
competition uh in in the great powers
and this is on the back of the alcus
uh agreement that was just actually
agreed with uh the us and australia
which uh much to the annoyance of the
french so i think this is a continuation
of uh britain's place uh in their in a
post-brexit world global britain and it
looks like they're forming alliances
with canada which uh obviously wants to
protect its flank against hostile powers
in the arctic region so i think that's
what it's all about